2020 was supposed to be the golden year
for Airbnb it was supposed to be the
year that Airbnb went public they were
supposed to be the hottest offering off
this year in just under a decade Airbnb
went from a single air mattress for rent
to a global company valued at more than
30 billion dollars the Home Sharing
giant has thousands of employees over
three million hosts and seven million
listings in over 220 countries it even
branched out with a new division called
experiences which allows guests to book
outings but travel is now at a
standstill
Airbnb plant listing is in doubt
expected revenue is down by at least
half and CEO Brian Chesky said 25% of
staff will be cut so how did one of the
most successful startups of the decade
become such a vulnerable company
everything B was founded in the optin
math of the 2008 financial crisis a lot
of ordinary people had lost their jobs
and we're looking for secondary income
once the idea of sharing your home with
someone took off a lot of people bought
into that promise you know we have
revenue from day one and we didn't
actually need to raise money at any
given point we decided that we invest
ahead of growth and we've always tried
to think about it like a throttle so
that we could at any given point
throttle into profitability Airbnb was
profitable by a certain measure in 2017
and 2018 so that gave investors a lot of
confidence and excited everyone really
about the prospect of startup like this
that has become a household name around
the world to go public these are
beautiful homes the company spent big
during this period of growth
administrative costs increased a hundred
and thirteen percent between 2017 and
2019 as they hired thousands of
employees and built out a corporate
headquarters in a trendy San Francisco
neighborhood then 2019 ended with a
tragedy
Airbnb now says it is banning house
parties that after a shooting left five
people dead in San Fran
sisqó in a suburb there on Halloween
night this Smosh shooting was really a
moment of reckoning for Airbnb and
that's what led them to invest over a
hundred million dollars into safety
initiatives these expenses helped bring
Airbnb s total costs to 5.3 billion
dollars last year more than double what
they were in 2017
you had board members grilling some of
the executives and saying hey your costs
are outpacing your revenue growth let's
read that in let's control that and then
of course the pandemic hit and changed
everything for me
China says the number of people infected
by a mysterious respiratory virus has
more than tripled over the weekend in
January officials in China issued local
travel warnings and restrictions
following the spread of covin 19 it
wiped out bookings overnight in China so
remember at the time no one thought this
would become a global problem and then
on March 11th President Donald Trump
announced new international travel
restrictions as Airbnb bookings foul
Chesky held in person meetings with
employees to discuss what these new
developments meant for Airbnb and their
plans to go public what was happening
was a lot of anxiety was building among
employees because a lot of them have
stock options and those are set to
expire later this year which meant that
if they didn't go public this year a lot
of valuable options that employees hold
would just be worthless
so mr. Chesky really took it upon
himself to reassure employees to say
it's gonna be okay we are still very
much going to list this year that
changed in a matter of days by the end
of March
he struck a more cautious tone he held a
videoconference with employees where he
said everything is on the table around
this time many guests began to demand
refunds for reservations but Airbnb had
a longtime practice of allowing hosts to
set their own cancellation policies
but in a world where you have guests
fighting back and saying hosts are not
giving us any refunds what's there being
we gonna do about it I think that really
shook the company as well this led to a
sudden decision by Chesky to give guests
refunds for certain bookings after
backlash from some hosts Chesky issued
an apology to them I'm sorry I'm sorry
we didn't consult you as partners and
I've heard for you ever since that
decision
Airbnb said it would pay host 25 percent
of what they would have received for
canceled bookings they also created a 17
million dollar mortgage fund to help
top-rated hosts cover mortgages by April
the company had barely any revenue
coming in from short-term stays so they
ended up raising a billion dollars in
debt at a very high interest rate that
is associated with distressed assets so
overnight Airbnb went from being the
Silicon Valley unicorn
that is a household name around the
world to being reduced to business that
is in distress on may 5th Brian Chesky
announced massive staff cuts in a memo
that has drawn praise for addressing the
impending layoffs with compassion and
clarity Chesky said nearly 2,000
employees a quarter of Airbnb x'
workforce would be cut
he also said 2020 revenue would be less
than half of what it was in 2019 I think
everyone would be very surprised if they
choose to go public later on this year
what I'm hearing from investors is that
Airbnb would need at least two good
quarters before they go public the
pandemic has shifted Airbnb in
fundamental ways the company is pivoting
to long term stays and recently rolled
out cleaning guidelines to help guests
feel safe whenever they do return to
rentals the sudden collapse of the
Airbnb economy that was a lifeline for
many has also exposed deep cracks in the
sharing economy if you think about it
Airbnb is really a property manager
without the property risk unlike hotels
that run and manage their properties
Airbnb doesn't own any of the properties
the pandemic has really held mirror and
has really made us all question the very
fundamentals of the sharing economy who
takes on the risk